how has this mind virus spread so
quickly and so contagiously because that
is a great question hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster i'm
konstantine kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts you may remember that a
few months ago we had Helen pluck Rose
on the show who was one of the
co-authors of the grievance studies
papers and I'm pleased to say today we
have her co-conspirators James Lindsay
and Peter pegasion welcome oh yeah I
forgot to say different location well
here we are social justice you guys have
just been speaking at a social justice
speaking truth to social justice
conference yeah we were there we enjoyed
it
most of all ready us to know what social
justice is about but for anyone who
doesn't just give us a quick lowdown
before we get into the meat of it what
is social justice and what isn't that a
great thing social justice justice I
mean that's a good thing isn't it just
social justice is two things at once and
that's the trick so you have this nice
thing that's about trying to overcome
disenfranchisement and discrimination
and racism sexism so on did so try to
make society actually more fair to treat
people with respect based on mostly
their immutable characteristics although
they dip into things like class a little
bit hopefully class is still mutable and
then you have this ideology that's gone
in service to this goal and kind of just
upended the thing like to give you an
idea of how upended it is you can take
some of there's a fellow on Twitter who
has gone through some of the biggest
books of the kind of the social justice
academic pantheon and it seemed like
Judith Butler for example it starts
listing who does Judith Butler cite and
it's you know this postmodern
philosopher that post modern philosopher
this lunatic that lunatic and then you
have this guy John Rawls this is this
philosopher who has this very famous
book called theory of justice and really
lays out what is social justice
you would look like on a liberal
perspective how many times is he cited
it was zero they almost never talk about
the other side of what social justice
means which is what most people think
social justice means which is what most
people actually agree with in support
whether they're on the right whether
they're on the left where there's
somewhere in the center whether they're
you know whatever the politics most
people agree that a more fair society is
better and something worth trying to
generate and so you've got this kind of
two things like in my talk yesterday I
pointed out that you know even in their
own books they admit we're doing
something different than what most
people think they say you know we do we
call ours critical social justice to
distinguish it from mainstream stand
points and you know some people call it
social justice to try to tap into its
true commitments but we mean something
else so there are two things there's
there's this idea that society can be
more fair and then there's an ideology
that claims to be working for that in a
very specific way that's basically
post-modernism the philosophy
post-modernism and grievances we took an
argument University is that essentially
they're trying to have a revolution
revolutionary social revolutionaries the
goal is they do don't take my word for
it go look it's like everything they
write they want to take the current
system which would be liberal systems
advanced democracies tear down how they
work and replace them with a social
justice system which is rooted in
critical theory which is openly not
liberal anti-liberal in fact and so you
say you're talking about anti-liberal
they are not keen on freedom of speech
they tend to see freedom of speech is a
right-wing issue or my favorite term is
a racist dog whistle I never knew what a
dog whistle was and now all I hear at da
boys's
why is it the freedom of speech is
you've seen as right wing to social
justice people that's a good question I
can I linger on something Jim Lehrer
wake
in their way so James mentioned John
wall's was an American philosopher
contemporary American philosopher
recently died the thing about John
wall's and the theory of justice is that
he says that these ideas for what a just
society is irrationally drivable and he
gives you experiments that you can do
that are very easy to construct you in
five minutes if you want but the basic
idea there is that every single
individual is able to use there's au
niveau Calla t of reason reason speaks
in one voice so we're able to rationally
derive principles of social justice i
don't think that the social justice
advocates with an uppercase S&J i don't
think their principles are rationally
drivable at all i don't think they're
univocal i don't think an independent
rational inquiry could come to the same
principle so they're explicitly
irrational it lee irrational and and i
think that's a fundamental difference
but that leads into your question is if
but the the problem with speech or the
idea of speech is that you could take
this in many different directions but
one is if your principles are not
rationally drivable then you need some
way to enforce them
you need some mechanism there to pick up
the slack between whatever the belief is
and the reason that you have for
believing that and part of that is you
just don't allow speech you don't allow
debates you consider debates platforming
I think Judith Butler and an article she
she co-authored called it non-consensual
cold platforming sexual assault article
was put up beside another person's or
article and one was a pro and one was a
con which is right normal does debate
that's how we I'm not saying it's the
best way to do it but that's the
traditional way to do it there's there's
no violence there and in my talk us I
spoke about how they conceptualize
speech as violence which is part of the
problem and so the
so they have mechanisms to enforce but
she doesn't actually mean speeches
violin isms they have bias response
teams and then these mechanisms act to
limit not just freedom of speech but
what they're really eliminate
eliminating is calling of Liberty yeah
yeah and so the way that I view it it
comes down to how you are free to pursue
your truth and in the social justice
universe there is a certain truth that
isn't ideologically driven truth it is a
dogma and that's just what it is and
anything that prevents you from thinking
in one way so if we can limit speech so
you won't think this way that's a good
day but it's even more than that and
this is something you guys talked about
I remember we had Douglas Meyer in the
show about two or three weeks ago and he
was talking about I asked him do you
feel like we live in a society where is
now dangerous to say the truth but
actually what you guys are talking about
is that the whole point of social
justice is to erode the concept of truth
as an idea at all to to teach us all
that there is no such thing as truth
that's true the truth is this invention
of the patriarchy because this is who
had power and the truth is a negotiation
or a combat or a piece of combat
essentially between competing power
structures right so there is no truth
anybody can the truth is it's not quite
no truth that's the truth is relative
yeah so I'm saying and why they're
saying it yeah and so truth is a
contrivance of power the truth is a
political construct is the way they see
it so there's no truth in the sense that
you know the correspondence theory of
truth is it's called it what we call
true somehow corresponds to reality
there's no truth in that regard
within this or as you know some of the
more moderate even the old postmodern
thinkers like Richard already put it the
truth might be out there but we can't
get it it was kind of the idea we're
stuck in our biases and everybody has
biases and everybody's biases are
basically equally bad so if there's
truth out there fine but we can't get to
it so
it's kind of the the to give them as you
know as much credit as they deserves
that the truth is is inaccessible so all
we have left our politics which seemed
like that idea for a second let me just
finish thing Francis this and I put the
silent a question to Helen when we had
her on the show if we were living in
Nazi Germany right now there would be
some scientific truths that would be the
product of the power structures of the
time right we would believe
scientifically that black people are
inferior phrenology right now so is
there not some truth to this idea that
what we believe to be true including
scientifically is a product of the power
structures of the day is that not some
truth to us so it's possible to call
things scientific truths that don't
qualify what you often find and this is
kind of a norm that's breaking down and
maybe it needs to break down I don't
know but I always think back in times
like this to Carl Sagan who's very
famous you know science he's a scientist
and also a science popularizer and
unfortunately he's mostly known for
being the latter somebody who spoke
about science very eloquently wrote
about science very beautifully the Carl
was not particularly well received for
doing this so within scientific
communities most scientists I mean you
do have your arrogant get here and there
but there are lots of them actually but
there's this overarching kind of norm or
understanding that everything that it's
doing is provisional and I mean when I
was doing physics physics is sort of
special because physics is really hard
anything that's not you know twenty or
thirty years old is kind of you know
maybe unless it has something like five
six sigma confirmation all those
extremely high confirmation levels so
there's sort of this attitude that
there's science which is this very
cautious self doubting process and then
you have kind of the image of science or
almost like some people call it
scientism is like science going too far
it's like what you would see out of a
science journalist it barely understands
the science and you know it's like they
figure out some chemical can inhibit the
growth of a cancer cell or something
like that and a petri dish and the
CEL happened to be for like a turtle or
something like that and then they write
you know like bananas cure cancer
because like science says so the thing
that gets called science may not
actually be science once you acknowledge
that then you can say yeah they had a
point things that were it recognizes
carrying scientific authority and
promoted as such and still are promoted
as such can be used as tools of power
because well you'd be a fool to argue
with science
therefore it's right therefore you have
to defer to that and that's actually
kind of a pound yeah and I think a few
keys here one is the provisional nature
which he just should've just talked
about and the other is there's the
science and then there's the policy
implications from that science so so
there are just needed points and I just
target a Michael Shermer about this
about how if you look at global climate
change the vast majority of beliefs
about global climate change
follow along party lines but that
shouldn't be the case those are just
facts what you do about it should of
maybe even of course follow along party
lines so there are facts those facts are
just you know does does is global
warming anthropogenic for example it's a
very complicated question but we seem to
have a convergence among people who have
PhDs in climate science that the answer
to that is yes and what we do about it
is a different question so you know the
whole Nazi Germany thing you take that
as provisionally true and then you ask
what political inferences one can draw
from that and that is a function of the
pre-existing ideology and the framework
in which that fits right so these
postmodern thinkers you know they were
looking accurately at the world not
according to their critics at the time
that the scholarship was a bit sloppy
apparently but we'll give them a lot of
credit we'll say they were looking
fairly accurately at ways that the the
history of how science was being used
and of course finding wrong answers the
idea of a science of courses that you go
from
wrong answers to les wrong answers to
les wrong answers it's not that you go
to right answers
it's les wrong all the way down and so
this is happening but if the answer is
just less wrong it's still wrong and so
you had you know these theorists like
Foucault in particular and Michele
Foucault was very interested in saying
oh well we thought about homosexuality
this way in this era and that was wrong
it caused all these problems and then we
got a little bit more knowledge and we
thought about homosexuality in this
other way and there's also madness he
did homosexuality and madness where his
two big big things that he investigated
like that and now you know we thought
about this way and it still caused all
these problems and we thought about it
this way later and it still caused all
these problems but if you look it's like
the the scale of the problems actually
just keeps getting smaller it does cause
problems but the scale of the problems
is shrinking but he doesn't say that he
says oh well there were problems and
then there were still problems and then
they were still cries so it's just a
cynical read on the history of progress
and touching on science as well you were
told you were talking about your
speeches some very exciting developments
at the social justice movement has done
in science including engineering signs
and how is it actually affected the
scientific community so the idea there
is that again who is asking the
questions and for what purpose so
science ask questions tries to answer
them who is asking those questions and
for what purpose are they asking them
that's what's at the heart of what's
going on and so it is a realignment of
the commitments of who's going to get to
ask the questions and what the purposes
are and their purposes are going to be
social justice emancipation or
liberation which means following their
rules so something like woke Engineering
would first of all prioritize changing
the way the engineering is taught the
way the engineering is engaged and maybe
there's something to this in some degree
so that more women are interested
particularly women would be interested
in becoming engineers
is that not quite a sexist concept this
idea that you have to change engineering
to get women to be interested yeah Helen
pluckers is really keen to say that what
this actually does is just continues the
old sexist idea that men are the default
human and if women aren't making choices
and the same proportions as men then
they must be something must be wrong it
used to be the view so this is really
common is to get the same thing
backwards and kind of go the opposite
direction with it it used to be that you
know women didn't have access or
something like that or we're told that
they couldn't you know you're not good
at math cuz you're a girl kind of
attitude and now it's the system itself
must be the thing that's keeping women
out all we socialize women to think that
they're bad at math or we socialize
women not to be interested in working
with bridges and helicopters or you know
city streets or whatever happens to be
and if we just change how we educate
people especially women but also boys so
that they don't get too encouraged you
know however then we can kind of twist
the system so that more and more women
will become interested we see in other
words they think that it's this weird
social forces systemic so flank sleaze
right it can't possibly be that there's
some psychological difference on average
not in any specific individual because
they're all biology or else right I mean
the parent Cohen Studies on being
friends since then it's very clear right
there are a few value evident oh yeah so
on average there there seem to be some
differences and of course now we're
talking in statistics and people freak
out on you talkin statistics because
they see on average it's different that
means you think that they're different
well not for most people those people
lay your land in the overlapping zone in
the middle when you get out on the ends
which is where you have in particular
your high performers in any given field
who's gonna become an engineer the
people who are worst at it no the people
are best at it and so the highest
performing people with engineering
talent are likely to become engineers in
many cases and if it happens that the
averages are even slightly different in
the the statistical bell curves you're
going to end up having more men say than
women who are
interested in the same reason why
prisons are filled with men right the
most violent people amend their for that
too right and so this this approach to
thinking about the world taking about
social justice is what's called social
constructivist and so what it believes
is that that can't possibly be the
result of anything innate to biology and
men and women that has to be the result
of how society treats men and women and
so if we can just shatter society and
rebuild it to where we don't treat men
and women different in any way yeah we
should probably linger on that because
I'm sure you have a question cuz that's
such a weird idea okay it's properly
weird I mean it's almost like the term
for its defamiliarization they often use
that concept it's almost like a Helen
described it really well it was like an
alien came down and has never seen a
sexually reproducing species before or
sexually dimorphic species before and is
trying to without interacting and not
reading you know the science or anything
just watching from above trying to
figure out why is this happening and all
they can see are the social interactions
they say oh well boys tend to play with
trucks and Legos or whatever and girls
tend to play with these other dolls and
whatever and so clearly the parents are
giving them the dolls and their
grandparents are buying them these kind
of toys versus that kind of toy and
they're being told this is what it's
like these a boy you know there's a
viral video in around a few guys watch
it if you show you haven't you should
watch it like 30 times where the kids or
two little boys are stepping on the
trash pan lid and it pops up hits them
in the face and they laugh and laugh
boys know so they would they would they
would look at this and say well someone
has clearly taught those boys that
violence is fun and funny and so we have
to figure out who's teaching them that
and they think that it's not just that
their parents or grandparents pose is a
thing that's pervasive through all of us
were all complicit they say in this
system of socialization
and so basically imagine it that every
possible behavior you can imagine is
somehow learned by being taught that by
society there's nothing in a we're the
only animal without any kind of insight
and if you can somehow change the
institutions in society you can create
an equality of outcome right and so this
isn't me let me be fair this isn't
totally crazy because we are and we are
a species that's like a hyper social
ultra social I think it's a phrase for
it so there is a lot of actual you know
social influence on these things and if
you look at history it's very clear you
can mold and bend that the thing is as
if there's an underlying biology which
shouldn't be a controversial point then
there are also limits to how far that
can be molded and bent and that's where
they cross off the rails
almost everybody would get in this
conversation take although there's the
biology people and then there's the
social construction people that's that's
an incorrect characterization there's a
social construction people and then
there are the biology plus social
constructive and then you have a handful
of weirdos that are like no it's all
biology a handful of weirdoes it
basically nobody respects it almost
everybody that's reasonable on the topic
recognizes that biology play some
influence covariant yeah and and so a
socialization plays some role and those
interact somehow and then you have these
social constructionist who are like nope
they're the way there's another end yeah
there's not a few of them there's rather
and so we're talking about this and yeah
you know and there are some merits so
what they're saying not a lot but
there's some merits why is it so
dangerous why can't we just say look you
know if these people have these ideas
that's fine and they're more than
welcome to them and you should read some
of the accounts there they're charming
online where somebody's talking about
the challenges of trials and
tribulations of raising a gender-neutral
child they decide that they're going to
raise their child without any reference
to gender identity they're you know
they're always gonna they're not gonna
put them in blue or pink or whatever the
different things trucks enjoy and
they're like why is my little girl
always choosing dolls no matter how many
times I buy her a truck or why is she
putting a dress on the truck you know we
try not to have gendered behavior and
she just keeps choosing it what do I do
she must be picking it up from society
everywhere so then when you start to how
is it so dangerous I don't I don't know
how trying to force something on
somebody that doesn't match whatever
their proclivities are doesn't result in
something that's at least suboptimal
like I grew up in in the southeastern US
which is a little bit behind the times
and so in the Bible maybe I don't know
if you've read that book it's an
interesting
hey man I'm from Russia we're still
living in that you may know that they
mentioned it's like 27 times that being
left-handed is a sin it's something
they're gonna double its sinister or
whatever so I actually know one person
who because he was born left-handed had
his left hand tied to his body until he
was something like 7 years old for most
things especially when he was at school
or having to do writing tasks he had to
learn how to use his right hand even
though he's left-handed and there's been
some study there's enough people that
have gone through this too where there's
been been some studies on these people
and what you find is find out is that
they're almost always as adults
ambidextrous so you can use both hands
very well the thing is is that all the
evidence we have points to the the idea
that they will never be as good with
either of their hands as they would have
been with their
and if you just leaned in to write what
their natural proclivity was and so
there's the threat there of when you're
limiting people limiting people yeah the
other there are further threats of
course which is if you think that the
the mechanism for something is if you
have the wrong diagnosis for the the
disease the prescription you get is
probably gonna be wrong so if the
prescription if you believe that oh my
child won't conform to the non gender
roles that I was trying to force upon
him or her what do I do it must be
society now you have this mission well I
have to break society because it's
perverting my child and so at that point
you you're limiting your child
potentially which you also get bent on
this mission that tries to break apart
the structures of society but if the
structures and society have some
correlation to the same underlying
problems that you see it problems that
you're seeing in your child you can't
break them without forcing it on people
when you start forcing on people all
kinds of weird stuff happened hey guys
we've got very exciting news about a
fabulous live show coming up within the
next couple of weeks
absolutely on December the 1st we are
going to be interviewing titania McGraw
in the flesh it's going to be absolutely
fantastic and hilarious because both
Francis and I can get destroyed for
being straight white and male and
afterwards we're going to interview two
Tonya's creator Andrew Doyle who is a
good friend of ours it's going to be a
cracking show you're gonna laugh your
heads off you're also going to enjoy it
if you enjoy interviews so come along
it's on December the 1st it's on
December the 1st is at 3 p.m. it's at
the Bill Murray comedy club and if you
want to go to the website
www.marykay.co.uk/awilliam only got a
few tickets left so you're gonna need to
be quick so let me ask you this Peter
because I find it very interesting you
talked about social justice as being a
mind virus or an occult I think he also
is that was that you that said that
so here it's invasive
that the right okay even so these ideas
are dangerous right let's take it as
given how has this mind virus spread so
quickly and so contagiously because that
is a great question well this is the
thing is I'm afraid no one really talks
about this but is it is it that they
found a way to weaponize that empathy is
it in a word something that Douglas
Murray would say in a world without God
we have found in your religion is a
dismissed achill thing that we have a
craving for is why is this a powerful
yes spreading there that's a great
question I've thought about it quite a
bit
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
basically stealing this best question no
no question what one thing we should
probably talk about is the substitution
hypothesis why don't you take a stab at
that and at all oh yeah so that's the
Douglas Murray idea so the substitution
hypothesis this is idea that you know
people have left traditional religions
so now they're looking for to get those
psychological and social needs met by a
not traditional religion in this case by
politics for most people I think that
there's something to that but not a lot
to that because the way that that
normally it's approaches well people
need meaning in their lives yeah they're
looking for meaning and they used to
find meaning in God now they can't find
meaning in God so they're gonna find
meaning in social activism or whatever
happens to be their pull up their
political stuff and there's I don't want
to say oh that's not it because it's one
of these things there are multiple
factors involved in why people turn to
religions if you look at the psychology
of religion and one of them is that and
that's certainly going to be an issue I
think that you're gonna find more of an
issue there because as our economies go
increasingly towards service those are
less fulfilling jobs and people are
looking to find meaning not so much
because they lost God but because
they're losing meaning in their careers
but what I ultimately think is that the
root of this is a problem feeling out of
control which is a result of a
polarization and so we're so polarized
we're so afraid Helen and I have called
this existential polarization that we're
so afraid that the other side will get
power and misuse it that it'll cause
existential threat so so we see this
extinction rebellion going on right now
is its extinction no kidding that we
can't possibly let the other side have
any power and that that's a crisis of
feeling out of control and so when you
feel a crisis of feeling out of control
then you want to reassert control now we
can add in another element this fourth
companion Mike Nina that's doing the
film about us and our work he has this
really interesting hypothesis right now
that video clips work kind of like
miracles and today's social media
economy so when did all of this blow up
and spread so quickly is right after
really right after the black lives
matter thing
yeah thanks right so you have these
videos a minute and a half long side or
a minute long or 30 seconds long you
don't really know what happened and then
a narrative is attached to it turns out
later primarily that the narrative that
was fun widely was not correct - no not
at all correct and so but this spreads
like wildfire so now you have many
people who feel like societies out of
control they feel like there's probably
a lot of race issues especially after
coming out of in the United States
Obama's presidency the Conservatives
today in the u.s. like to pretend that
they do they weren't from racist as hell
that and I'm like why that was oh what
some of them were I'm not all of them of
course but holy [ __ ] I mean they were
burning black effigies and you know I
saw people with bumper stickers driving
around where I live that said stuff like
it's called the White House for a reason
and the Confederate flag I mean there's
Confederate flags everywhere and they
were really bad during during Obama's
presidency all through the south so
there's a lot of people are aware that
there's still this racist resentment and
that is that's racist resentment there's
nothing else to call it and then all of
a sudden you see racist cops and that's
the narrative that's spun off of the
miracle story video and boom that crisis
of control just goes nuts to everybody
and all of a sudden you have these
people critical race Theory since the
1980s have been writing down exactly the
explanation for this Society is hidden
racism racism never got better from Jim
Crow era it never got better even from
slavery it just kept putting on a nicer
and nicer white mask hey whether I call
it that so it's all still there all the
same resentment all the same inequality
all the same racism is during slavery
Jim Crow are still there they just
present themselves nicer and then all of
a sudden you have proof you have this
miracle video that's proof of that
theory and people very rapidly turned to
the critical theory to start young
people on the left in particular who
were most worried about these issues to
start getting an explanation and so
these critical race Theory sanon gender
you have you know the equivalence with
queer theory post-colonial so and just
right across the board all of these diff
a different approaches they all of a
sudden had the answers that a panicking
left was looking for and then you'd had
the condition which was that the
shooting in Ferguson that was in cast as
a racist event of course he also had the
Trayvon Martin shooting which I don't
know if that was racist or not that
one's really morally ugly so you have
this kind of series of events and so you
have lots of people all of a sudden
saying we finally have an explanation
and genuinely I think a lot of the
people on the left in general and
certainly all of the social justice
reactionary type people firmly believe
that things like critical race theory
and the rest of this social justice
scholarship is like having discovered
the germ theory of disease but for
bigotry hmm and so they think we now
have the diagnosis and this is the thing
we have to fix and in many ways it's a
simple solution to an incredibly complex
problem in society it's an over simple
solution yeah and that's why it won't
work I mean it completely gets again it
gets everything backwards it starts by
what we're gonna reified differences in
identity we're gonna make differences in
identity matter more we're gonna make it
more difficult for people with different
races to talk to one another and find
common ground because we have to be
constantly aware of the eggshells or
land mines you might step on when you
interact across any line because as
Robyn D'Angelo tells us racial dynamics
are always present between people of
different races and the question is not
did racism manifest in the situation
it's how off ring has a manifest in the
situation is it's assumed that there the
racism is there so if we speak across
many racial and the racism is there and
it's just a matter of time or a matter
of digging to discover how it actually
every time you do you joke about me
because I'm brown
we have created a generation of people
or almost a generation of people who for
whom everything is a problem everything
there's racism and every interaction
there's racism and every film there's
racism and and if you don't see it it's
because you're a racist
I'll give you an idea of how verdict
kills to this last night during one of
the panels now I'm going to admit this
and somebody's gonna go looking for it
I'm just totally I'm cancelled I was
sitting there kind of like this with my
hands worked in my legs and my index
finger and thumb were close together
while the other three fingers are
resting on the chair and then suddenly
because I was just kind of like out of
it it's like long day and I suddenly
realize because I've been holding my own
finger like this and I just kind of let
it fall apart and I suddenly realized oh
no I'm doing the okay symbol between my
legs at this which is now the white
nationalist symbol cuz for Django stupid
thing yet and so it's like I
accidentally ended up in that somehow
and then I realized I was in it and then
I was like we're in the middle of a
panel and all I could think about is
[ __ ] how do I undo this smoothly how
what's going to happen if somebody
notices this and it's like it's taken up
it's ridiculous and now I'm devoting
cognitive energy to this that I didn't
even have to give to anything at that
point
and so now multiple and not me but
multiply this by you know everybody
that's constantly got to be aware of
frankly stupid [ __ ] all the time
yeah I can't not because there was a
video I think it was an MSNBC guy as a
black guy and someone made the symbol
behind him and even if it was
manufactured by 4chan what a horrible
thing for that guy he's just he's just a
guy who happens to be black who some a
nice one your show yeah yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] some racist prick is making a
symbol even though these are the other
idiots made the whole thing up in the
meeting like how horrible he's just a
guy doing his job and then he has to
deal with all this [ __ ]
even though and this is part one even
though they manufactured it if you're or
if you're constantly looking for things
like that juice mean what happens is
when and you're in a situation in which
someone does it intentionally and
there's a black guy there like that's
obviously a problem well that's the
thing though it's not obviously a
problem and here's what I mean and this
is a this does create a real problem how
do you know that that guy wasn't just
cashing in on the joke knowing he's
gonna go viral because this is really
freaking important because if it's just
a troll and everybody wants to be a
troll now because you can go viral yeah
now we've lost the ability to tell is
this guy being racist I was also
sticking up so now we're losing the
ability to detect genuine racism where
it occurs because we have to pay
attention to stupid [ __ ] yeah that's
certainly true and from the book
definitely true and how horrible for
that guy I mean what's horrible for the
guy is that he has it it's not even the
symbol or even if necessarily the guy
was a racist it's that he no longer can
tell and he has to go through this whole
ordeal now he's now the subject this now
goes viral over something ridiculous his
face in it and so now he has to deal
with what was that racist wasn't racist
people talking about oh my gosh people
saying oh that was horrible just like
people's doing just now and then other
people say you know downplay it kind of
like I was doing this now and it's like
everything just becomes morally
ambiguous and something that should be
relatively clear and easy to pick out is
this something racist happening or not
sometimes it's a little ambiguous but
it's usually fairly easy used to be
fairly easy to tell a lot of times now
it's kind of as you were mentioned that
dog whistles now it's like this universe
of ambiguous dog whistles you know if
somebody's pulling a joke you know
somebody's just being stupid you don't
know if it's genuinely racist you don't
know if it's like racist joke at the
same time it's impossible to tell so
when you destroy the ability to detect
genuine racism and you make it all
ambiguous you start attacking the wrong
targets you start going after the wrong
things you start just wasting resources
if the guy was a troll and they start
wasting resources trying to fix his
racism he's having a laugh mmm he's just
laughing the whole way through it and
made him famous maybe infamous with it
at the same time the whole thing is a
tragedy the thing that bothers me about
it on and on a broader level as well at
the level of societies this hyper
racialization of society forces us to
think in terms of race all the time like
that's exam I self doing it I was I was
driving to to one of our interviews a
couple of weeks back and there was a
black girl waiting to cross the road and
I literally found myself thinking I
better stop and let her pass because
she's black correct now there is no more
racist thinking than that that you have
to treat people differently because of
their skin color and we've imbibed it
we've imbibed it because all this
[ __ ] yeah that's exactly right if
they get everything backwards and so the
real threat there Helen talks about this
frequently is that we're going to see as
a pushback continues to mount is it is
already mounting as it continues to
mount we run a real risk now of actually
resurrecting and this is their biggest
fear resurrecting genuine racism that's
correct and they're I mean I didn't get
it I wanted to talk about it but the
conversation went away honest last night
I wanted the panel's so I can mention in
here no there's a great talk I watched a
long time ago on YouTube by Dan Ariely
and he's talking about frankly though is
a psychological mechanism and he's
talking about why is why his Catholic
confession exists what's it for
and so psychologically what they figured
out it's probably the root of that is
that people sort of have on their moral
calibration they kind of have a kind of
a [ __ ] it line you know like I'm trying
to be a good person to it it's hard and
trying to be a good person you can think
about this with people trying to stick
to their diet I mean clean I'm eat and
clean I'm eating good I'm not eating
crap and then you have a couple days
where you travel and you had too many
beers and you're eating cake and you do
well everybody looks good or whatever
happens to be depending on what you're
into and you overeat and you eat badly
and you try to get back on track and
eventually you cross the line and you
just go bad enough and then you're off
your diet completely and this turns out
to be with all moral behaviors so you
have a line where oh well I'm not a good
person anymore
so [ __ ] it I'll just not be a good
person and what I really was discussing
was that the discovery was a confession
gets you in front of a mechanism that
resets you above the line so then you're
trying to be good again well which is
really interesting yeah well here's the
thing you're a racist you're a racist
you're racist you have to think of
racial ways sooner or later people are
like will [ __ ] I'm a racist and then
where are they going yeah and there's no
mechanism to come back yeah there is no
right the mechanism they offer is awful
so most it's not like you know the
Catholic confession I grew up Catholic
it's not that painful you go in there
you talk to the priest
hopefully nothing we were having someone
else makes a PETA photo since I was here
he shows me every two weeks now
and it's like I know I'm gonna to say a
rosary for that ant and so you know but
you do the whole thing it's not really
that difficult of a process and boom
you're back over the line with this it's
you have a sign-up for a lifelong
commitment to soul-searching and
political activism yeah and if you step
out of line so much as ever we're gonna
remind you of what a terrible person you
are forever so you have no way to get
back over the line so now we're in this
real risk where you know traditional
gender norms are starting to become cool
again
on certain parts of it that's horrifying
and then genuine racism you're gonna get
people below that [ __ ] lining like all
right well let's do the symbol
everywhere you know whatever it is let's
just go nuts and why can't I say the
n-word to whoever I want and it's just
you really don't want to break whatever
societal the societal the tante exists
that keeps most people above those lines
trying to do it right even if they don't
always always measure up you really
don't want lots of people to start
falling below that line or decide that
that line doesn't matter anymore
[ __ ] it okay I'm a racist so you're
talking about forgiveness really that's
why yeah forgiveness and those things I
mean if you can cancel somebody for
tweets they made twenty years ago even
when they were a team as a teenager like
they were some stupid thing when they
were 16 years old or now and like their
30s or whatever I guess I couldn't
written a tweet that long ago but you
know you get this they uncover some dire
injury or something oh you wrote this or
that if you can cancel somebody for that
you deny their ability to grow their
ability to change their ability to try
to
on the right track and stay above the
bad line and you offer them know their
what forgiveness is in that that's no
all you messed up because you were at
answer we're all stupid or were
teenagers we all did stupid stuff 14
years whatever it is even me saying we
all did stupid stuff and when we were
teenagers somebody will clip this out of
context possibly and say oh this is a
guy with something to hide well if
you're gonna do that please make it go
viral thank you very much yeah you know
there's you know what you're talking
about but it's the impact on your mental
health as well if you're gonna look
every single thing that you were saying
and analyze every single moment I mean
that's just a fast track to getting
anxiety then in a break now not only
that that assumes that there's some kind
of moral stability right so for all you
know the moral norm could change I mean
the moral norms have changed around 53
the moral norms of chance very radically
give an example I was taught when I was
a kid and I've asked other people my age
and similar experiences that when you
shook hands of the woman you were
supposed to shake you're just supposed
to offer your hand like power and you
weren't supposed to yell okay the guy
there was a different kind of Wow
now today that could possibly be
interpreted as sexist right right so
because you're treating people how you
know but even something as little as a
handshake but that could be today the
zeitgeist is race and gender and things
were that identity level salience but
maybe tomorrow it's either something we
can't imagine my own prediction for this
has been that will start if if a vestige
of cancer culture exists the next moral
frontier will be factory farming oh that
guy a factory farm meat cancel him or
that woman that person so the moral
norms always change so as I said before
about the tying the left hand down
there's something that's incredibly
psychologically alienating because
you're not allowed to speak because your
first question about censorship and thus
as I said in my talk you can't form
those authentic relationships because
you don't know what anybody means and
everybody's walking on eggshells and
you're not looking at people as people
oh there's a black woman across the
street I have to let her go and I catch
myself doing that too and I have to just
rub that out
because I'm in that milieu or that's I'm
just constantly bombarded by that like
this is the this is how we have to look
this is how you have to think of people
it's a really toxic way to think instead
of just a person all is a black person
oh there's a gay person right and you
talked about the you talk about the way
that that's anxiety inducing and yeah I
don't know if that's by design or not
but we were just talking a few moments
ago about how you can have of that I
think that the root of this is feeling
people in a crisis of control yeah
they're they feel out of control we'll
give them anxiety right now they feel
even more out of control and that
becomes kind of a you know a problem
that just kind of keeps going from from
the perspective of having studied
religious psychology before getting into
all of this business that's what I
really got into before I got swept up in
woke land I was learning that one of the
I got really interested in conversion
mechanisms how do people convert to a
religion or religion or a cult how do
they get induced and the mechanisms
nearly always the same whether you do it
with a child or they do it with some
adult with children it's obviously much
easier is that you induce the state of
vulnerability and then you give them a
pathway out of the vulnerability through
the ideology or the cult so here you
give them identity silly name too
well well you have anxiety you know well
you're an anxious person you're not a
person with anxiety that's something
they could be treated there'd be
medicalizing it that's the foucault
daeun idea that you you can't do that so
you're you're an anxious person so now
this is who you are
you're you you you are anxiety and so
you give them and then you know the way
it is to lean into that victimhood just
lean into it and come come with us and
be activists and and we can fight this
problem that makes you an anxious person
even though that's the thing that's
causing me to be anxious
so you give somebody a you do smaller
ability you manipulate their
vulnerability make them feel usually bad
or guilty or something and then or
afraid fear of Hell for example you
might think about and then you give them
a path out of that alcoholism hell scary
blah blah blah Blee if you just believe
in jesus and you don't go to hell free
pass away from that he died for you you
don't have to go and so it's a way to
create anytime
this have emotional manipulation that
that taps into some path of
vulnerability have you've been complicit
in racism don't you feel guilty about
that because you're white and that means
you're comfortable and you don't have to
think about what it's like to be a
racial minority and what they have all
the crap they have to put up with Ursa
Mac well did you know that you know if
you take up anti racism you know you can
do something about that it's not even
you're not allowed to do it to make
yourself feel better yet so it's like
constantly self-flagellating that be
positioning yourself or myself I guess
is a good white if I did it and that's
that's for voting you can't do that but
you give people you say oh well you can
end the system that's creating this
problem all you have to do is sign up
for a lifelong commitment of
soul-searching for how you're complicit
in it and spread it to all your friends
miss I think it makes a pause to see
more difficult yeah oh sure
well we've got about 15 minutes left and
I want to end on a more positive note if
we can you guys this wasn't positive but
we need someone to dive into it and take
the hit for the rest of us to maybe look
for a way out and you guys have just
written a book which is have to have
impossible conversations right I've had
a good look at it it's a very
interesting book so chart for us some of
the paths out of this because I put it
to you that the vast majority of the
public intuitively agree with what we're
talking about here yeah the exhausted
majority yeah I talked about in my in my
comedy show in Edinburgh Festival this
year I talked about the fact that most
people are terrified to say what they
think and they are I mean that is a fact
right so most people get this but I feel
like on an individual level none of us
really know what to do about it
how do we get out of it I mean the show
we try and do is about trying to create
something that gives an out to all these
feelings and a solution so tell us how
do we get out well the solution that I
advocated yesterday is hearkening back
to the Greek value of parody Zia which
means speaking truth in the face of
danger speaking boldly and speaking
bluntly and speaking honestly but before
we can even do that we need to think
about what it ha to speak to people
again because we're losing that because
I agree completely we're walking on
eggshells people are afraid to say
what's on their mind so they need some
basic tools for how to have a
conversation so the for example really
listen to someone try to figure out what
they're saying if you don't understand
ask place the burden of understanding in
yourself don't say oh that wasn't clear
so I'm not sure I understand that you
place the burden of understanding on
yourself well hold on Peter sorry to
interrupt but I just I'm listening
through the prism of an ordinary person
and I'm going well look at you you did
your parodies there you spoke the truth
look at what happened does we get called
natis because we have conversation with
people like you right well we're all
right a Jason all this crap right how
many people we had a guy who was fired
from his job in a supermarket because
she shared a comedy routine about
religion from Billy Connelly one of the
greatest comedians in the history of
this country on his Facebook King on
fire okay so let's take a step back so
Socrates had parrot easier they killed
him the state kill they like mention my
talk Malala she was shot in the head
there is the solution yeah there's no
wand that you can give and we're gonna
get out of this mess this is a
catastrophe
yeah and so you know if you look at what
they do to us and the fact that that you
guys were painted as Nazis for talking
to us
I'm Jewish by the way doesn't protect
you right you see what happens to brett
Weinstein and ben shapiro etc that's not
a prophylactic against me that's good
don't deny your your nazi nature because
there would be nazi fragility and i
would
[Music]
so we have to be honest that if you if
you want to dig your way out of this
you're gonna pay a price for this right
it's just no way you can't sugarcoat
this to people in fact that itself is
very easy before you jump in is 400
years ago yeah the four of us and
there's a few more of us in this room
right now who would we'd all be burned
at the stake
right right right now our tongs pulled
on right you've lost your job where I
have my job but I've lost considerable
right you know the whole comedy industry
in this country hates us because we are
right-wing or whatever right you know
all of us have paid some price but we're
not burn at the stake
no we haven't been kicked off YouTube we
can still make a living from doing this
you know isn't isn't isn't the kind of
all right I mean we kind of all right so
people were he touched me with this all
the time like what do I do I was
terrified that my friends and my family
died here that more I hear my two things
I hear a lot of my job and my friends
and my family are gonna get rid of me
one or the other and what do I do
well you mentioned 400 years ago people
being burned at the stake you know how
that ended is people getting together
having conversations like this but not
with cameras they got together actually
in small groups often in bars where
there is a lot of ambient noise or pubs
or whatever in spoken low voices and so
what I tell people thinking back to that
I know they created revered the
Reformation they created you know
liberal movements of liberalism itself
and out of those conversations and they
couldn't be overheard because it was you
know treason to speak against the
monarchy or the the episcopate and so I
tell people all the time
reach out to people pay attention I mean
we love social media right now unless
you get banned from it and pay attention
if you're smaller you're not gonna get
banned probably unless you say something
pretty ridiculous okay pay attention
find people who are speaking out against
this follow them pay attention to who
interacts with them reach out to those
people and start making your own social
network speak in direct message
the scenes get on whatsapp which is
encrypted you know meet up with each
other whether it's virtually whether
it's in person and start having the
conversation so that you guys can find
your feet understand what you need to
understand realize that you have you're
not alone you're not crazy you're you're
their lot that's a hopeful message you
can start to speak with that courage
yeah because you you know you have a
fallback you have a group who's gonna
back you yeah
you know you're coming from a place
where you've kind of figured some things
out and you're not just shooting in the
dark so I don't be able to do that all
the time the thing is is the there is
safety in numbers if more and more and
more people start speaking up then it's
not as risky for any of us who are
speaking up and there really is
something too
you just have to know who's voice not to
listen to yeah you know you you just
have to know we are obviously not Nazis
yeah we're not even Nazi adjacent it's
me question and for someone to call you
that they kind of opt out of an adult
conversation so there's no reason we
ought to listen to them I mean he's
already a norm on Twitter that started
that if somebody I mean I don't
necessarily advocate this of course but
it's it's got some it's got some weight
behind it that if somebody has pronouns
on their bio you pretty much just regard
whatever they seem sooner every time I
see some vitriol some particular
nastiness click on the profile
invariably pronouns it doesn't have to
be that I mean anybody who slings abuse
at you on Twitter do what I do mute them
right away
they gave abuse or they give abuse to
other people like if if you respond to
me and somebody abuses you that person's
are I'm never gonna see that person
again I don't care if they're right like
you disagreed with me and they're on my
side if they sling abuse mute gone and
if enough people are doing this long
enough it will create a norm to where
slinging abuse isn't getting people what
they want and they'll burn themselves
out and it just won't go anywhere so I
really encourage liberal use of that as
well and then you just have to endure
the fact that people are gonna say oh we
don't have conversation well the law no
I won't have conversations in the wrong
forum with people whose goals
abuse them if it's not a conversation or
different I'll add to that if my my
golden rule is if someone has harassed
me and there's a considerable number of
people or is currently harassing me I
will not have a conversation with them
that is that's just not an option
anymore but we talked about the route
out of this just to kind of finish when
we say find your guy said find your feet
you know get what people find your feet
there are three things really they have
to be done that's what we tried to do
yesterday and each of us kind of spoke
to it differently
but we've got it we've got to expose
what's going on here that's where I was
talking about that the picture on the
social justice box the diversity and
treat everybody with respect doesn't
match the contents which is this kind of
totalitarian ideology that the
difference so expose that make it clear
how you go read some of their stuff and
then share it in context it's horrifying
people don't like you said most people
won't agree with it once they see what
it really is you just have to get past
that branding which is really good
second is if you have the time and
energy maybe not everybody does try to
explain it if you guys have a show have
people on who can explain it if you can
read a few of their their books or key
papers or articles that people are
writing on you know outlets like aerial
magazine or cool that or whatever
happens to be learn to explain what's
going on with some of this again people
don't really agree with it and then if
you can't start looking for alternatives
can you if you care about social justice
I get asked this a lot I care about
social justice but I don't like social
justice warriors what do I do
look look for and start articulating
other ways how can you do the right
thing like you're saying it's like maybe
we shouldn't be thinking about race all
the time maybe this whole thing like
putting race first
maybe we should ratchet that back down
maybe we should ignore people who tell
us that we have to pay attention to that
all the time and so you want to look for
but you know we still have to care and
take people seriously so maybe the
lesson out of that is let's listen a
little more than we did before let's
take it a little more seriously not be
so quick to dismiss if that's still a
problem I'm not sure if that's even
still a huge problem maybe it is but
fine it's good advice in any case and
then let's investigate but not just
listen and believe crap not shut up your
story's been told no well we'll listen
well we'll check it out and you can help
us check it out and it's all fine so
look for alternatives that aren't just
coming from this place of ideology that
the liberal approaches so that's what
Helen was talking about like it let's
just find ways to do the the thing let's
take their complaints seriously figure
out what's real inside their complaints
and let's address those things until the
whole thing from them and what advice
would you give to somebody who's working
in a particular industry or a company
that is overtly work it's a great
question
so I don't ever tell anybody
[Laughter]
stick out their neck if you have the
ability to do it what I often tell
people when they ask me that is though
after diversity training what should I
do blah blah blah I say take notes
taking some very detailed notes and
understand exactly what they're saying
try to get a very clear picture you try
to challenge it on the spot they're just
gonna make life difficult for you it was
no mistake that one of the papers we
started to write but didn't have time to
finish was things like if you go to
diversity training we'll give you a
survey did you like diversity training
if you say no you have to take more
diversity training or you get sent to
diversity training and he gets called
him as a character witness and you know
like do you think he needed a diversity
training you say no no he's a great guy
it was a misunderstood now you need
diversity training you know so if you
call it out on the spot once this
stuff's been institutionalized you're
just really causing yourself yeah
there's nothing wrong you do at that
point you know make no assignment start
to understand it go out for drinks with
your colleagues who also don't like it
start talking so you won't talk either
story I have another idea for you guys
as you know someone recently bought all
our video equipment for us that is
actually someone who works in the very
work industry so if you want to change
things you took your no man she's got a
patreon pages all day yeah saying that
to to give them money sounds good to us
yeah that will solve the problem the
magic wand P is to give them money
no seriously start talking to each other
and if you challenge it directly so
wrong like start understanding it so you
can explain it you can expose it and
then you can start articulating
alternatives yeah and we just wrote a
piece about how important it is to
listen it really does start with
listening because people will either say
well though they don't actually believe
that well I actually they do yeah and
you should listen to them and when our
pieces argue that you should listen to
them and believe them not believe the
content of the speech but believe that
they believe it and then once you do
that you can say okay now I have a much
more clear understanding of this in a
professional context the the idea is the
same when you have to go to these
trainings some just take really good
notes and listen and really understand
what it is the what what is this
ideology once you really get it then you
can start speaking up because you're
coming from a place where it can't you
you can't easily be shut down or refuted
so start paying attention look into what
they're saying oh well this comes from
this book go read that book see what's
there
well that's been one of the great things
of doing the show for us is we've
educated ourselves on these issues so
when we get invited to write or speak
about it we are very comfortable that we
actually know what we're talking about
right that's key did you like our book
I'd have impossible conversations yes we
did very much so yeah and we recommend
that people get it yeah you definitely
give them money we set all that up and
advise just recommending each other
stuff listen guys the one question in
the spirit of educating ourselves and
having an opportunity for audience to do
the same as we always like to give our
guests an opportunity to talk about
something that's left field so the last
question we ask and we'll ask you to
each of you separately is what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
that we should be talking about any area
whatsoever anything in the whole world
anything in the whole world I mean some
people are talking about the thing that
I would say I'm this isn't what anybody
would expect a nuclear power we there
should be a lot more conversation on
nuclear power I hear all this this stuff
about renewables and green energy and
you know great you know but there's a so
much resistance especially from
environmentalists which is so strange to
nuclear power I think we need lots more
open-ended clear discussion that
first of the science you've got to go
again educate yourself a little bit
people need to get more clear on
actually in general health safe and
clean nuclear power is and how it
actually is something implementable on
large scale rather quickly and if we're
looking at environmental problems and
taking them seriously as I think we
should it's it's something that just
keeps falling in this crack because
everybody doesn't like to talk about
nuclear so you probably didn't expect
that that we are not talking enough
about nuclear power and we should be
well this is one of the food safest
forms of energy and I say this is
someone whose wife grew up right next to
Chernobyl so yeah it is very very safe
what about you Peter I'll throw you a
curveball now one of the best things
I've done as a parent is I've placed my
kids in an immersion program at the age
of three so if something language
emerging language immersion program
affects Mandarin so someone has a child
when I was in school you got it in
seventh eighth and ninth grade that's
way too late it's got to be as young as
possible so that they don't even know
that they're learnt even having
awareness they're learning it so that's
been a gift that's paid a remarkable
dividend since I've done that people
thought I was insane too but that's one
thing I would suggest if someone's a
parent is to put their kid as early as
possible in an immersion program
language immersion and you've picked the
right language as well you're really
free to proofing their boat I don't
remember what the number is of big
tanker ships or carrier ships not like
aircraft carriers those are already
nuclear but you know cargo ships and
cruise liners and things like that and I
remember what the number is of the
biggest ships that we run which is
something like seven equals in the term
amount of exhaust pollution that they
put out from burning diesel is equal to
all the cars on the planet or something
like that but boats are the easiest
thing to put nuclear reactors and to
drive them of pretty much anything we
already have all the technology so not
just even nuclear power but nuclear
powered vehicles the all of our big
scales sea transport can be done with
nuclear power and cut down if you're
worried about atmospheric emissions
there are actually workable solutions if
you just go nuclear you'll never win a
Nobel Peace Prize no that kind of took
these prize from my role in exposing the
crap in the Universities yes well they
go the campaign begins here well listen
guys thank you so much for coming on we
really appreciate your time and your
thoughts follow both Peter and James on
Twitter they're very good and if you do
follow them that it's a very kind of
mentally healthy contribution to your
intake if you follow you guys so we'll
put the links in below get the book how
to have impossible conversations is
absolutely fantastic and we will see you
again in a week's time see you later
guys thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger point and also leave us
a nice review on itunes and spread the
word